the Joe Rogan experience he still looks
great yeah he looks so healthy like I
don't know what he's doing but god damn
it that black don't crack [ __ ] is not a
lie I mean look amazing he's he's got to
be close to 60 yeah and he looks at 30
yeah he really does how old is he
58 okay let's pull up a recent picture
of Eddie Murphy pull like when you saw
him with Jerry in comedians in cars
getting coffee he's driving around with
cherry he looks great
yeah said Jerry cuz we're tight right
there he looks like like in Beverly
Hills Cop he's like he's just thinner
there's just young and I don't mean
thinner that he's fat now I just mean
he's like wolf dogs he's both that I'm a
man yeah yeah he was a it was
essentially still a child that he's so
healthy looking yeah he look what he
[ __ ] he's doing look at that the photo I
mean he might be 36 yeah he does not
look like he's almost 60 I mean that's
mainly Tracy Lou those gold chains those
are Posterous zoom in on those gold
chains again what what in the [ __ ] Tracy
that's out of Walmart money we're at the
cellar and Tracy Tracy brought jelly
beans and he was like he was like yeah
talking about the jelly beans like we
don't have access to them with our money
you know like but I can't do any
impression so this is gonna be the worst
Tracy Morgan you ever heard of it's like
I got jelly beans
who else you know good Brooke jelly
beans and then he's like eat him eat two
jelly beans he makes like all of us eat
jelly beans and he goes not to green
ones
what are those emblems one of them is
Jesus yeah that's a TM on that okay
Tracy Morgan a big TM a plate I can't
tell ya what is that one the back hard
to tell if I thought they broke that
[ __ ] thing has gotta be heavy you must
hurt your neck yeah it's like a bike
chain go down scroll down there with
Eddie Murphy with that beautiful young
lady
scroll down scroll down scroll look at
that yeah dad's girlfriend I think
my partner whatever oh but he's um
divorced right isn't he yeah look at
that I think she's had a baby recently
Wow still fertile yeah 85 years old she
was hot she looks very actressy hot slim
waist nice booty congratulations Eddie
but look at him he's [ __ ] almost 60
years old it looks amazing
look at him this is amazing
yeah whatever he's doing health-wise
incredible this is why one of all people
in Hollywood who like look like that I'm
like just tell us what are you doing
tell us what you're doing I know we
probably can't afford it well I could
probably can't afford it but like tell
us what you're doing so we at least have
an idea but there's some crazy [ __ ]
behind look at that [ __ ] picture look
at that picture right there like as your
water from a different place him vitamin
this is him for dolomite right oh yeah
he's doing press almost 60 years old he
looks like he's 15 years younger than me
at least I'm looking side-by-side in the
screen now not bad trust me but I'm
pretty healthy but I party a little too
hard like he's got like he's got like a
little wrinkle right here like a little
crease in his face a little character
lightly makes him look a little bit
better something that he only has one
earring sign of the times
right oh yeah one diamond earring like
I'm not gay gonna have to that was
that's a big [ __ ] earring too boy
that is a look at the size of that
earring that's like a [ __ ] quarter
million dollar earring Dimond it's good
it's a big diamond big-ass rock for your
ear he had done well he's done why I
don't know if you've heard about it and
you know he did a thing a few years ago
right when Cosby was starting to get
into trouble
when I don't know if you saw it but he
did like this thing where he was at a
panel and he was receiving someone
warrant he started doing a little
stand-up and talking about them taking
away Bill Cosby's awards and Bill
Cosby's uh his his what is it was a yeah
yeah I've set in 28 years and I'm
telling you his he was so sharp did you
see it no I remember I've watched it
back then I can't really remember what
he said it's really I remember watching
it back then and I remember being like
this guy two weeks on stage he'd be fine
yeah lady Sharpe if he had material
he's [ __ ] sharp yeah sharp his attack
I mean how great did you know his
brother did you know Charlie that I
didn't I mean a huge fan of his as well
he was the nicest guy I loved that guy
that was a bomber that was a huge bummer
Charlie and I did a tour together in
like 2007 we did like 22 cities you
travel together for the whole month like
the whole month together he's the best
he was so nice he's so cool just just a
[ __ ] great guy
yeah it was a big fan of his too and a
guy that was basically a famous person
first and then started doing stand-up
which is the hardest way to do it it's
definitely the hardest way no one wants
to believe you know you're on stage and
people like you're famous you see you're
a plus act that I paid money to see and
you're basically an open mic er yeah and
you get and people paying to see you
yeah so he started out he would host
that's that is a very smart way to jam
art dude he would host and then he would
you know slowly work up enough material
that he could do a set you know he was
an older guy - yeah one that happened I
mean he was deep into his 40s when
things really started clicking for him
might be an open mic ER and famous and
in your 40s now I mean
[Applause]